le mâle de seveso prend de l'ampleur le
nuage polluants a franchi les cordons de
carabinier et les herses en travers des
routes autour de la première zone
interdite de cette région du nord de
l'italie
certains enfants des maladies de peau
d'autres des nouveau nés des
malformations encore inexpliquées
rien ne dit bien sûr qu'il ya une sorte
de rapport avec la dioxine
mais le mutisme du corps médical et des
autorités alimente la rumeur
en attendant que les experts donnent une
réponse s'ils le peuvent
les habitants de la région ont peur
surtout les futures mères seveso c'était
il ya neuf mois
victor drame en sept mois se sont
écoulés et pourtant on reparle de seveso
comme si le nuage de dioxine venait à
peine de s'échapper de luz inique mais
ça c'est que la dioxine s'est de nouveau
manifestée d'une façon particulièrement
cruelle sur le corps des enfants et des
adolescents de seveso
car la dioxine c'est aussi cette maladie
de la peau cette espèce d'acné juvénile
qui n'en est pas une et qu'on appelle
clora cne parce qu'elle serait dû au
chlore contenu dans le nuage toxique qui
s'est abattue sur seveso
qu'y aura-t-il après la claque nez et
puis comment se fait-il que sept mois
après la catastrophe on ait trouvé dans
les écoles de seveso des doses de
dioxine dix sept fois supérieure au
niveau disons tolérable la réaction des
autorités locales a été immédiate
fermetures et des infections de toutes
les écoles mais il faut bien préciser
des infections et non pas des
contaminations puisque personne n'a
encore trouvé le moyen de détruire
complètement la dioxine
pourquoi n'at-on pas décelé la dioxine
plutôt qu'irresponsable le maire de
seveso se cache derrière les autorités
régionales
la région semble dire voyez le
gouvernement et le gouvernement mettent
en cause la fatalité pourquoi pas il
évoque la dioxine est aussi imprévisible
et désarmante qu'une fatalité la dioxine
qui en principe s'était déposée dans la
zone a est sorti et a commencé à se
propager dans un certain rayon autour de
la zone initiale nous sommes en train de
faire des prélèvements sur le terrain et
nous avons des résultats déconcertant la
dioxine ne s'est pas propagée de façon
uniforme mais de façon désordonnée
les habitants de seveso ont peur comme
on peut avoir peur de quelque chose
qu'on ne connaît pas les premiers
enfants de la dioxine sont nés dans des
conditions normales c'est vrai mais
c'est à peine réconfortant quand on
pense qu'il ya une quarantaine
d'avortement parce que les futures mères
avaient peur de mettre au monde des
enfants un orme
j'ajoute que les experts français que
j'ai consultés cet après-midi recommande
une certaine prudence avant tout
jugement définitif